hi I'm Willem Dafoe and this is the
wired autocomplete interview give me
[Music]
here we go
okay what is Willem dafoe's real name
William James Defoe my father was
William I was William I didn't like
Billy I was looking for a nickname a
friend called me Willem and then when it
was time to actually have a name on a
program or something it felt silly to go
back to my birth name so I felt like
Willem I used Willem okay where is the
from Willem Dafoe was born in Appleton
Wisconsin which is a place that Harry
Houdini better known well Harry Houdini
Houdini grew up there and also Joan
McCarthy lived there how did William the
folk start acting as soon as that doctor
spanked me that's where it all began how
does a woman default stay in shape well
you want to know
it depends what I'm doing but normally
I've I've been a yoga practitioner for
many years what is Willem Dafoe like in
real life you're looking at him baby
geez will Willem Dafoe ever play The
Joker I doubt it it's not the worst idea
in the world but I've got other things
to do too was Willem Dafoe CGI and no
way home no I don't think so yeah there
was a couple of shots that were really
fuzzy I thought it was silly because the
de-aging thing they don't have down yet
and what's the point I don't look that
much older
I don't think anyway it's the creams
okay who does Willem Defoe
look like I look like myself I look like
my mama I look like my daddy
I played a fish called a black moor and
what was his name Jay Gill Gill of
course how could I forget wonderful
wonderful experience what was Willem
dafoe's first movie that's a tough one
but I suppose the best answer is the
Loveless which curiously enough was
Catherine Bigelow's first feature movie
all right Clan Willem default can Willem
Defoe yes he can uh can Willem Dafoe
sing
oh that'll shut him up Ken Willem
default dance absolutely that's my
favorite thing to do but only in certain
circumstances Ken Willem default paint
you mean like a house
are like a work of art I did learn how
to paint for the van Gogh movie and it
was very special because not only did I
learn how to paint and not only did I
enjoy it and not only did that root the
character but it really gave me a
different Insight in how to look at
things
does Willem default
speak Italian
Aroma does Willem Dafoe live in New York
yes
sometimes oh look at that one you know
when people ask me whether I speak
Italian I always get all flustered
because I expect they want a show
particularly if they don't speak Italian
does Willem Dafoe like Robert Pattinson
yes I saw him the other night and he's a
Charming bloke
because people sometimes think we are
our characters does Willem Dafoe have a
brother I have two brothers and Five
Sisters
have Instagram no
I have doctors in my family one of my
brothers is the transplant surgeon one
of my brothers is a lawyer some of my
sisters are nurses a writer we got lots
of things going on why will him try
the best Green Goblin because he was the
first Green Goblin is that a good answer
okay why is William Defoe a meme I don't
know
why did Willem Dafoe help John Wick
because I played a character that's his
friend and I like Keanu I like the
director and I liked him that's probably
why I did the movie why does Willem
Dafoe have an accent everybody's got an
accent what is my accent what do you
think my accent is
you aren't interested
um is Willem Dafoe classically trained
hell no
I'm trained though
I behave myself
it is willing to a professor no but I
have taught and I do I am the holder of
two honorary doctorates so you can call
me Dr Defoe
I I think the Arts it's not of chemistry
or physics that's for sure is Willem
Dafoe vegan ah sort of I basically am
vegetarian but I do make exceptions I
sometimes eat eggs I sometimes eat
cheese I don't eat meat for good reasons
is Willem Dafoe an American Psycho yes
he is I play a detective that suspects
or doesn't suspect Patrick Bateman is
Willem Dafoe coming back as Green Goblin
well that is a good question
that's all the questions now you know
all there is to know about
Willem demon
[Music]